hello everyone I hope you're all
enjoying your Sunday as we have another
very nice game from the Paris
Grantchester rapid event it's a game
from round one Hikaru Nakamura versus
Fabiano Caruana
so the two teammates are going to brawl
it out before we check out the game we
do have a couple of nice photos to enjoy
here is uh well just for you to check
out the venue there are the spectators
you can see a nice big screen for
everyone to see all the board's grisha
here also seems to prefer checking out
the boards in the 2d preview instead of
just you know checking the actual boards
even though he has access to all the
players but it's not something you know
extraordinary a lot of people prefer the
2d view to the to the actual 3d boards
so there's that and also here we have a
nice photo of the handshake between the
two players before the actual game there
you have it Nakamura and Korra wanna you
can see that well there there there is
no eye contact which is something very
that happens very often in a high-level
chess and also you can see that Nakamura
doesn't have a single bottle of water
with him it's hard to say why this is so
maybe he just decided he will not be
thirsty as it's only a rapid event maybe
his sponsorship with a redbull doesn't
allow him to have any other you know
branded bottles next to him or maybe he
just lost the Red Bull sponsorship I
have no idea maybe he's just protesting
to all the plastic bottles so that's why
he's out of it but you know it really is
a mystery we're gonna have to check out
more photos from the other roster to get
to the bottom of this but getting back
to the game Nakamura has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 with Knight
to f6 c4 e6 and Knight to c3 inviting
Curran off to a nice nimzo-indian and
Caruana
accepts with Bishop to b4 nimzo-indian
defenses on the board and the e3 with
castles by Caruana
Bishop to d3 and now c5 just challenging
the center nice to eat you defending the
d4 pawn and now even d5 so a lot of
tension in the center
Nakamura trades ones with but pawn
captures pawn captures and now castles
and now the main idea is just ninety six
continue to develop your pieces
here Caruana chooses a very rare line c4
which does grab more space but on the
other hand it leaves the you know the
fight for the central squares unattended
so to say as you will not no longer be
able to challenge your whites d4 pawn so
much of the c2 and the white will be
able to challenge your c4 phone whenever
white feels like it would be three but
okay nice to see c c6 Caruana prepared
this line and now there are two games
that reach this position one continued
after we won continued b3 just
challenging the super bond right away
but Khurana sorry Nakamura plays a3 and
it's a new move in this position so it's
Nakamura who surprises Caruana in this
situation with Bishop 285 and only now
f3 so Nakamura probably found in his
home analysis that the inclusion of a3
is good here for white with rook to e8
pressuring the the e3 pawn and now we
have b3 finally challenging that c4 pawn
we have C captures Bishop captures and
now Bishop to f5 just developing the
bishop to this nice diagonal and g4 now
I did inclusion of f3 not only to Kuwait
the d4 and e4 squares from black's
knight but also prepared the g4 with
Bush up to g6 and now Bishop to d2 just
nicely developing you can't develop it
over here as the e3 pawn would hang but
you don't really want to
we have roped the c8 Khurana just
continues developing with rook the c1
and now comes Bishop to c7 if you try
something like h6 to prevent g5 as you
know why he wants to push g5 right away
this really weakens the g6 Square Knight
to f4 would be very strong here as now
you will either have to allow a nice
capture some g6 or there's a triple
attack on your d5 pawn you will probably
have to capture on c3 you know way
you're gonna have to give up the bishop
pair
so instead Bishop back to c7 by Caruana
and now g5
with Knights to h5 and now f4 bye-bye
Nakamura currently f5 is not a threat as
Queen characters and g5 will come with
check but at some point if you know
you're not careful you might lose your
piece here so nice the east
seven Khurana now guards DF v square
additionally with Bush up to a four
grabbing more space and forcing the rook
to move away from such an active file
will group to f8 and now Knights the g3
again taking control of the f5 square
now f5 definitely is an idea so here a
corona trace with Knight captures H
captures and Bishop to a5 Mac edit again
the idea is to put pressure here
probably maybe even capture the night
and then maybe put your Bishop here on
e4 which is a very nice diagonal with g4
by Nakamura preparing f5 now to finally
trap this Bishop and here like I said
it's possible to go for characters
capture send Bishop to e4 it's just a
very nice idea where you control h1 you
can go for ideas like Queen d6 or b6
followed by h6 maybe you can go Queen h6
Queen h1
all sorts of ideas become possible but
Corona chooses a different line first
Bishop to d3 preventing the capture of
the bishop with f5 now attacks the rook
on f1 so here Nakamura has to decide
either he will go rook to f2 like he did
in the game or he can go for a series of
traits for example night e 2 offers the
trade of bishops Bishop captures Queen
captures attacks the bishop here Bishop
captures Queen captures now a nice trade
of rooks
can occur and then at the end of this
well a long exchange line Queen a5 just
putting pressure on the bishop and on
the e3 pawn so you're you can either
move the bishop allowed this capture but
then you get this very nice rook lift
would rook to c7 or you can try to
defend it some like Queen to d1 but
again a 6 b5 will push away the best
robe you can grab the a 3 point so it's
a bit of a trade-off but black black
should have the upper hand here
so instead nakamura goes rook to F do he
decides to keep all the material on the
board and now Queen to d6 Fabi
now prepares h6 he wants to get his
Queen there if possible and then have
all sorts of ideas here with Bishop to
e1 now challenging the bishop here and
now Queen to a6 first favi defends on d3
and now comes Bishop to b3 with Bishop
captures on c3 free in d4 square 4
white bishop like we've already shown
you could have done this back then but
you know that there was no rush in doing
it with rook captures and the story not
real captures but Bishop captures in c3
and now push up the e4 finally grabbing
this beautiful diagonal and now like I
said the idea is h6 and hopefully you
can do something like this with Bishop
to b4 you still can't get rid of this
light square bishop this is the problem
because this Bishop isn't c3 here so
there should be four offers afraid of
roofs but also challenges the night well
with the night here with captures once
Queen captures and now rook the c8 on
pins and now the knight can finally move
we have Queen to f1 offering a queen
trait and now five defiance Queen to b6
saying okay you can capture my knight
but I'm gonna capture a bishop and
you're gonna lose very quickly my bishop
is much better than your Bishop I'm
gonna play rook c3 maybe capture here
and you will lose this game for sure so
after Queen b6 we have Queen to d1 now
taking control of the c2 square again
hoping for better up to c2 but Bobby
doesn't allow it we have Queen to c7
taking control of the C 2 square and now
comes rogue back to f1 with a 5 pushing
the best back Bishop to d2 and now comes
the Queen to b6 again the idea is h6 and
trying to break through on the Kings
side with a 4 by Nakamura and now
finally h6 so here if you capture like I
said you get this and then there's
really not much white can do here you
can start running away with your King
but this will end pretty badly for white
so here you probably want to play
something like Queen e1 try and get your
Queen maybe to help out with the defense
wait for black to capture on g5 if black
really wants to but here not more
decided to play g6 just put that pawn
keep the H file closed but it doesn't
help him all that much now corona play
tonight capture some g6 with Bishop
captures an 85 and nakamora grabs
another pawn and now Queen to a3 a
beautiful move by Caruana where the b3
Bishop is paralyzed you can't move it
here you can't move it here a black
really control the c2 square you can go
here and it's gonna be very hard to
defend here but from back
to d2 by Nakamura and now comes Knights
to h4 and now the threat is Knight to f3
check which really can be stopped here a
sturdier defense than what a Kimura
plate could have been something like
King f2 but still knight of three will
win the game the thread is the simple
Knight captures here and then after
Queen captures you lose the bishop and
b3 but even after Bishop c1 an attack
against the Queen you can play rook
captures on c1 and then after Queen
captures captured the bishop next or
instead you could try Bishop to a5 not
allowed this capture with the rook but
then Queen B to check and again you
either block with the Queen and lose the
bishop or you go here and then you get a
nice Queen to h2 mate so even though it
seems like a sturdier this defense it's
really not nakamura played g5 but here
karana just played Knight to f3 check
and it was in this position that
Nakamura resigned the game due to the
line we've just shown after the King
moves you're gonna just capture the
bishop Queen captures and well you just
hand your light-square bishop and it's a
game over for white not only are you
down a piece but you know it's it's just
a beautiful piece a true monster Bishop
nothing on the board can oppose it it's
just beautiful might even use this as a
thumbnail so yeah that's the game around
1 Nakamura versus Corona Corona won this
very nicely really just superior
performance and also we mentioned that
we're gonna check out the standings
after I showed one more game so there
you have it
Cara wanna in the lead with 5 points
also sharing lead with Martin and also 5
points then we have Maxime hologram and
young shift of Duda with 4 points with 3
points
Jonnie pony she and Alex and Alicia then
with 2 points he Cara Nakamura and the
Neil dubov and lastly with 1 point
onigiri and Sharma media of Momotaro
just finished winning the feeder Grand
Prix in Riga Latvia and then he had a
shaky start here so it probably takes
him a while to shift from classical to
rapid time format over there I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank cos
you cause you donal hughes Jimmy
Hernandez Borislav Milanovich and Clark
Archer for a confucian
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos serie thank all
for watching and I will see soon
continuing the short coverage of the
Paris Grantchester continuing the
capablanca saga and checking up on your
suggestions thank y'all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
Sunday